if you are 55 and older with an
underlying health condition
you can now get the coronavirus vaccine
yeah those eligible have more options
now to get their shot including at local
pharmacies bianca holman is live now
with what you need to know good morning
bianca
hey good morning alex good morning john
so yeah more people are eligible for the
vaccine that means our numbers are going
to rise as far as the people who are
vaccinated across our state and that's
because
again you can get the vaccine at more
locations like at local smith locations
across
the valley now here are the underlying
conditions that you must have in order
to be eligible for
this section so those with underlying
conditions
they are prioritizing asthma cancer
cardiovascular diseases
like high blood pressure and also if you
have copd so if you're a smoker
and of course the pharmacist on site
will go through your medical history and
the conditions that you must have but
the patients are not required to prove
their health history so it's an honor
system there
nevada has administered more than one
million doses of the coronavirus vaccine
and nearly 11
of our population has been vaccinated
and that's according to the cdc
and if everything stays on track even
more people could be eligible for the
shot soon
we will see how um the the appointment
scheduling and the access goes this week
as to um and then couple that with the
supply
uh that we hope to to see for next week
and then we'll be able to gauge
when we'll be able to open it for the
rest of that age group
so those in the 55 plus group with
pre-existing conditions they can make
appointments at places like smith's
albertson cvs walgreens and walmart so
of course
more locations open to a lot more people
they can get to it in their
local neighborhoods we've got that
complete list on our website at
8newsnow.com
because again you must make an
appointment before going to get your
shot reporting live from desert inn in
decatur bianca coleman
8 news now